right welcome to remedy in 10 I'm going
to show you how to cook the most amazing
dish in 10 minutes but honestly I don't
mind if you're 1 or 2 minutes behind I
guarantee you the tips and the inside I
will show you it'll fast-track that food
and who knows one day you may absolutely
nail it on 10 minutes today's dish is a
beautiful pan-seared sea bass where they
sort of Mediterranean light tomato
eggplant or aubergine olive chili sauce
I've got some leftover Chris Brooks
who's gonna be on the bass is actually a
start but this thing is an easy dish to
put together the most important all you
to do is get organized and so 90% of
this battle is in the preparation so for
the fish which are already fileted it's
a beautiful little baby sea bass and
we'll score it sear it that cooks in
about 2 or 3 minutes
eggplants cherry tomatoes garlic a
little bit of oregano and these little
calibration south and it's league
Chili's what's the longest thing to cook
that's what you could ask yourself it's
not the fish is the eggplant get the pan
nice and hot first and guarantee this
will be done in under 10 here we go
so literally top and tail and with
eggplant you know it's a delicious
vegetable the less time you have the
thinner you slice it there's no fast
track that's why I love using these
little ones and they're less bitter than
the big ones but more importantly once
they're crispy they are so delicious
olive oil in get that nice and hot if
that all of all isn't hot then the
eggplant actually starts to go soggy and
then they go greasy everyone worries
about salting them and then squeezing
know when they're this small the
eggplants do not need salting ok into
the pan and get a really nice sort of
crisp texture on those now eggplants in
the nice thing about this particular
source the source can be made and
literally it can sit in the fridge for a
day the longer it sits in the fridge the
taster is eggplants
in you'll see that oil get absorbed
straight away and that's why is going to
be hot so you get nice and crispy if the
pan is cold and the oil is cold the
eggplant will turn greasy and soggy so
get it nice and hot you'll see them get
beautifully colored from there start
slicing your shallots and this is the
base of the sauce now so we don't need
to find ice anything is a sort of rustic
Mediterranean take on a beautiful
roasted sort of sea bass I saw this dish
down in a little restaurant just outside
San Tropez and this is sort of a faster
version of it now you can see the
eggplant getting nice and crispy and put
a touch more all in there now and get
some color on there really really
important beautiful taste not bitter at
all and that's why I much prefer using
these small eggplant than the big ones
the big ones takes so much more time to
cook onions ready next to that clove of
garlic as well if you don't wanna slice
the garlic get a microplane and grate
the garlic I like the texture of the
garlic so slice it again nice and thin
again and then from there get your fish
and just lightly score the fish just a
nice little nick into the skin and that
will stop the fish from coming up and
again
two or three little slices down shots
garlic and tomatoes ready tomatoes a
beautiful little cherry tomatoes from
the vine they're so sweet they're gonna
go into the sauce or the very last
minute now that's it and now we're gonna
start cooking them eggplants deeply
colored and always once you've cooked
eggplant the most important thing is to
take them out of the pan after that and
just lightly drain them okay
I've seasoned them salt and pepper to
get it a little bit more exciting some
zest of lemon okay
zest a lemon so it gives it a nice sort
of citrusy delicious flavor now look at
that there's a glass a beautiful they
come out now they just sit there like
crispy they're beautifully cooked the
same pan start off with a touch of
waddle and we're not gonna over color
these shallots and garlic gonna go in
sort of just lightly done fish I don't
need to put on that takes literally two
minutes to cook that fish my pans
getting nice and hot on the side sure
lots of garlic in give that a really
nice little toss on this source looking
sort of rustic a little bit relaxed not
too intense I've got these beautiful dry
tomatoes in as well sun-dried tomatoes
in and they'll keep them hold and the
chili going to cut that into little
slices it's been in the brine and so
again it gives the sauce that little
touch on heat and gives it the right
amount of heat seeds in if you start the
scene
the use of swords coming together but
you got that color on the shallots and
the garlic turn down the gas really
super low plus more olive all cool that
down and then from there we'll put a
little touch of white wine she asked the
touch a tablespoon of white wine in
there Narvik so good reduce that white
wine down and then from there we start
building out the sauce okay I've got a
couple of tablespoons of vegetable stock
give it a bit of body and then from
there a couple of tablespoons of chopped
tomatoes take that off the heat
you see there's a really nice tomato a
Mediterranean sauce coming together lots
of cooked garlic cooked check on the
seasoning the heats in there
and now I'm gonna drop my tomatoes in
there literally without cooking it so
they go nice and soft and then finally
I've got my olives for saltiness and
then a touch of fresh oregano not a chop
this to put that over the source
just pick the leaves in so it becomes a
little more fragrant and like I said
this sauce can be made a day to three
days in advance as it sits in the fridge
it's so tasty
you all got onions and garlic and
tomatoes at home so it's a great way of
using leftovers and really makes a nice
refreshing sauce tablespoon of olive oil
on top and then finally take your lemon
and is great now from there
fish into the pan tops of all get it
nice and hot lightly seasoned the fish
and then literally into the pan down and
this sea bass cooks like salmon 90% of
it skin side down that keeps it really
nice and crisp but these little Phillips
literally take 90 seconds to two minutes
to cook beautiful couscous all I've done
here just walk the push goes back up to
temperature and the squeeze a nice touch
of fresh lemon juice into it gives that
nice vibrancy and it's a really nice
delicious garnish it goes so well with a
tsubasa beautiful yeah once you've got a
color on the skin that sea bass turn
that over very carefully we turn fish
once get the fish slice underneath
horizontally so you don't break the fish
up and over up and over look how quick
that cooked and then as that's cooking
and I've put a little touch of lemon
juice inside the fish which seizes it
usually not
lemon juice in that finishes cooking
that lemon juice goes inside now to
plate keep it simple this is dinner in
10 luncheon 10:00 brunch in 10 nothing
complicated couscous in the middle fish
is still cooking nicely I've turned the
gas off and it's actually continue to
cook from that heat the sauce I just
lift up those tomatoes I'm not stirring
not pressing you can see the olives the
garlic The Onion's the sun-dried
tomatoes all sort of melted into one but
makes a delicious sauce and then look
just drizzle around and then finally the
fish take the fish out one to these
beautiful crispy aubergine sits around
the outside and it's such a lovely way
of using baby eggplants and then finally
you ask the touch of olive oil around
the outside and there you go the most
amazing sea bass with a stunning
Mediterranean sauce that's not dinner in
10th that's dinner in 9 minutes and 40
seconds beautiful do not forget to
subscribe to my amazing youtube channel
and good luck can't wait to see what you
can do in 10